[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday June
28th welcome to my new backyard Hank
today we're going to learn how to be
microfinance ears it's kind of like
being a regular financier only it's free
and instead of being evil it's good Hank
the Dominican Republic resort we stayed
at was pretty Swank but we took one day
to go to the real Dominican Republic
where like regular people live and what
we learned there was that regular people
in the Dominican Republic live in
poverty in fact about 60% of people live
in extreme poverty in the Dominican
Republic and about half of those people
live on less than one dollar a day
people in extreme poverty have almost no
interaction with regular banking in fact
when we were there we saw people who
didn't know if you signed a check on the
front or on the back they don't have any
opportunity to have access to banking
because they don't have the kind of
collateral that loans require so they
end up in this cycle of poverty right
where they can't get a loan to get a
business and without a small business
they don't have any job opportunities
because there aren't really any jobs
because the economy doesn't function
very well and the reason the economy
doesn't function well is because no one
can get loans to start businesses so
microfinance organizations take the
poorest of the poor and they offer them
opportunities now the only kind of other
loans these people can get are from loan
sharks who often charge a thousand
percent annual interest Hank when we
were in the Dominican Republic we
visited with that wonderful group of
women who were just about to graduate
from their microfinance training they'd
spent five weeks learning the basics of
banking and also thinking about what
kind of businesses they were going to
start and then we showed up for their
graduation ceremony which was held in
their neighborhood the woman on the
bottom left in this picture was opening
up a shoe store the woman next to her
was going to sell Avon products the
woman directly two rows behind her was
opening up a cafeteria here's the
remarkable thing about this microfinance
organization we met with their loan
payback rate is more than 98 percent
that's higher than like most American
banks because these women know that this
is an excellent opportunity to have a
chance to get out of poverty they're
really good about paying back
their loans and then once they paid back
that loan they take out larger loans to
continue to grow their business in fact
as we were driving back from that
neighborhood
we saw a sprawling complex of
restaurants that was all started by one
woman who got one one hundred and eighty
dollar microfinance loan Hank I think we
can agree hold on I swallowed a gnat
stupid nature Hank I think we can agree
that microfinance is an awesome idea the
problem is that usually the people who
start these microfinance organizations
are like really really rich however
there is now this amazing website
kiva.org ki VA dot o R G that allows you
to be a microfinance a year you give
money directly to someone who's living
in extreme poverty and then they pay you
back Hank
it's like charity only it doesn't cost
you any money
so Hank as a project I propose that you
and I over the next week gives several
gifts to kiva.org maybe the nerdfighters
will join us Hank I've got to go back
inside and paint my office I'll see you
tomorrow
you